hey everyone its Mike from water flows
and it's been quite a interesting
morning in the S&P futures hey everyone
its microphone motor closed and I'm
shooting this quick video because you
know this morning in the futures markets
the e-mini futures markets it's been
quite a hectic morning you know you're
seeing ten point moves happening in less
than a minute which is quite quite a
move and I want to talk about what
happened this morning in the first
basically in the first 20 minutes of
trading really quickly while it's still
fresh in my mind before I forget about
it
but before I begin you know a brief
disclaimer you know this presentation is
for educational informational purposes
only
you know don't trade with money you
can't afford to lose you know and there
is risk involved in trading so let's
take a look at what happened alright so
let me just go back here to right around
the cash opening you know it was a very
very interesting morning a lot of
volatility a lot of buying coming into
the market and you know when the cash
market opened we were trading you know
it's pretty quiet we were trading wares
8:30 here we're training you know
basically 2879
right around in here market started to
come off and then the buying started
appearing very strong buying you see
this is a one-minute bar chart and
you're seeing positive deltas of 7,000
8,000 you know over two bars that's
that's very big to say the least you
know you're seeing some sweeping action
as the markets going up you see
imbalances in here but what was
interesting what was really telling that
made me felt like the market was gonna
go higher still is after you hit this
high here let me just make this a bit
bigger so it's a little bit easier to
read
I know sometimes on when the videos get
rendered on YouTube it's a little bit
harder to read I'm not so much
interested in what's happening in these
numbers here what I want to talk about
is these two highs here there's a double
top you know you got divergence
divergence so what does that mean means
you got a new high new or equal high
with negative Delta you know when you
got negative Delta you got aggressive
selling okay you know that's a bearish
sign again you'd pair up the high right
up here so you have two divergences then
the market starts to come off over the
next bar here at 8:42 look at the Delta
it's a bit lesser right it's 1040
three the previous bar was minus 12 17
and even the bar before that here the
negative Delta was minus 13 45 okay you
know it's not necessarily convinced that
this market is going to you know what
the direction is at this point you know
at any you know if I'm looking at this
market right here you know I'm thinking
okay it seems a bit negative right we
got the two divergences you've got the
negative Delta coming up here near the
high it looks like this market is you
know aggressive sellers are coming into
the market but then you know you take
the next bar minus 118 okay then min
delta is minus 480 well where's the
aggressive sellers where are they you
know yeah you have negative Delta but
you know if you're gonna come off this
high you want to see a strong negative
Delta you don't see 119 you know
especially after you're getting bars
here with 7,000 8,000 Delta just to get
a bar with 119 there's practically
meaningless then the next bar comes in
14:07 so what do you see and you're
seeing aggressive selling drying up here
okay where's the aggressive sellers for
the market to go down there needs to be
more aggressive selling at this point
I'm starting to think if we take off
this high well I mean we're gonna go you
know much higher and I didn't obviously
you know in the SPS we got a lot of
space to the upside to to cover next bar
it come right up there very strong Delta
again 1300 and then watch the next bar
boom it actually opened up here traded
down okay trading down what was
interesting we got to this area of thin
volume here we had eight that traded on
the bid you know and we held that area
we held this point of control we held
this point of control we held this point
of control again all bare bullish sign
it's not bearish excuse me all bullish
signs to the upside and this market if
you're watching it you know it started
trading down dot okay I mean maybe we're
gonna take off this point of control
take out this point of control but the
buying just came right back in there and
if you were buying just above this high
you know it was just a it was off to the
races off to the moon here higher higher
higher so again you know watch watch
what's happening in the
Delta especially you know at highs or
lows you know it can be very telling if
in this case the sellers are drying up
you know if the sellers are exhausted
you know the aggressive sellers are no
longer there I don't want to say have
pulled back or done selling but if you
notice that they are getting weaker you
know watch for the aggressive buying to
come back in and if the aggressive
buying comes back in the market a little
higher so you know that's what I wanted
to talk about again I wanted to get that
out because you know I was there this
morning watching it unfold and it's just
you know just an amazing move higher as
a result so you know if you're
interested in this you know tomorrow
August 14th 2019 I'm doing a free
training with investors Expo the hold
sign-up link is in the description if
you watch this video after August 14th
the link won't be there but you know if
you're interested you know sign up just
go to the link in the description you
know subscribe to my youtube channel if
you like this video hit like and thanks
everyone
bye-bye